hi everyone I am syrup
I'm an engineer on tensorflow and I have
been working on a bunch of stuff on
tensorflow 2.0 over the last two years
and I am very excited for this
opportunity to present to you some of
the things you have been working on and
some other stuff that we have added to
make tensorflow even more useful for
research so thank you all for coming
okay so first question why do we have a
tensorflow 2.0 why wasn't tensorflow one
good enough so when tensorflow started
like a few years back even before at
this belief the goal was to build like a
very extensible and very scalable system
on which you could run like train and
serve very large you know network so for
that the craft based methodology was
perfect because we could optimize
everything away as much as we wanted but
as a user breeze grew and lots of new
kinds of research started using tensor
flow for example RL we realize that this
craft based paradigm wasn't perfect and
like it wasn't very useful usable you
often had to like jump in and out of
this craft mode to do a lot of things
also there's a lot of new accelerators
that came up and now you like rarely run
your models on single machines and it's
not always straightforward to scale your
models from single machines to multiple
machines or clusters and things like
that so intensive flow to you tried to
fix some of these things okay so the
first thing we have added it is eager
execution so when you define a
computation in tf1
you build this kind of computation graph
you see on the right and so basically
you have this graph with operation nodes
and they are connected with data edges
and control edges and basically you get
these kinds of graph tensors and yeah
you get these kinds of graph tensors and
then you have to build a session object
is your bridge between your symbolic
representation to your computation in
tf2 you do not have to build these graph
tensors as soon as you define an
operation you get back a tensor of the
concrete numerical values this is great
for debugging
and yeah the one obvious benefit you can
see is in tensile force input pipeline
so TF data is tensor flows functional
kind of API for like loading your data
pre-processing it and using it for
training your models in TF one when you
have to use input pipeline you sort of
create an iterator object and then you
call iterator dot Katie next and then
each time you compute this tensor you
get a new entry from a dataset in tf2
when you build a dataset object it's
like a regular Python hit triple so you
can iterate over it using a regular
Python for loop okay so either execution
is great it helps you a lot with
debugging but there are very obvious
performance benefits using a graph based
model because you can develop
optimizations if you have like full
visibility over the computation before
that we have added TF function the TF
function allows you to convert the same
computation that you have in your eager
mode to run it as a graph for example
you have this extremely simple model
just for illustration which has a single
SDM cell and then if you want to run
this sub part of your competition as a
graph you can just throw in the TF
function decorator and then in this
particular example runs 2x faster so the
speed-up really depends on what kind of
model you have so if you have a model
with like lots of small nodes then
wrapping them as a graph if you are
asleep speed up but if you like try to
have like an adversarial example where
you have like a single node with large
computation you might not see much
benefit because the overheads of
creating functions and running MSI but I
think that's not that common so usually
you should see a substantial speed up
okay so functions intensive you have
polymorphic which means that you can
call a function with values of different
types and shapes and each time you do
that we have to retrace the functions is
basically convert your function from
Python to graph again for each new kind
of shape and type and that can often be
expensive so I'll show you how you can
avoid that and right now there are still
certain corner cases where we can do
better but we don't so in those cases we
raise warnings and tell you hey
something is wrong maybe you can
do this other thing which will make your
function tracing multiple function
traces go away so here's an example of
type polymorphism so you have this
function double axe which basically it
has X plus X you can call it with an
integer or float or a string and you can
also call it with different shapes of
values for example you call it here with
the scalar and then you can call it
again with the vector but as I mentioned
earlier now every time you call it with
the value of a different shape this
function gets free trade so you build
the graph so that is expensive you can
avoid that by explicitly providing an
input signature to your function that
defines a shape and a type for a tensor
and then each time you run be just you
don't retrace it we just make sure that
the value you're providing is at least
as specific as the shape in your
signature another cool thing that comes
with the F function is autograph which
basically converts your Python control
flow into grab control flow so when you
are in eager mode you obviously want to
use Python control so to like do a lot
of your computations and if you run the
same thing in graph mode it will lead to
a very inefficient crap if you imagine
unrolling all the computation multiple
times so a TF what autograph does is is
converts these kinds of for loops into a
graph level control flow like TF dot
while loop and it's also smart enough to
understand that say you have a break
statement it will update the condition
to check for these things so you don't
have to like change your mental model
when you are moving from eager mode to
graph for but this is not perfect for
example you still see something called T
after tensor which is tensor flows less
data structure in Python you would
expect to use normal lists and that is
something we are looking to supporting
over the current coming months another
thing that has bugged people in tf1 is
side effect or tree so side affecting
operations are those which when called
change some underlying state but don't
have an outgoing data for example if you
have variable and you assign a value to
a variable it just changes the state of
your variable but you don't have an
outgoing edge from that node to depend
on so if imagine if this function did
not have a TF function you would expect
the assignment to happen first and then
you do the modulus check and then you
perform the assign again but if you
express this as a graph since there is
no data edge from the assignment and
there basically from the right and the
read these can run in non-deterministic
order so this has often but people in
tf1
and you have to manually you add control
dependencies using theater control
dependencies and things like that in
tear function we track anything that can
depend on its predecessors and we make
sure we add the minimum necessary set of
control edges so that all your stateful
operations run in the same order this
does not mean everything will run in the
program order because that will be very
inefficient so you make sure that parts
that need to run a sequence run in the
sequence and everything else is
paralyzed okay so here's a very useful
guide into your function which is a lot
more detail okay so in tf1 how we
computed gradients was using TF dot
gradient so because you had a graph you
can compute the gradient of a graph by
doing sort of a backwards pass on the
graph and computing a gradient of each
node in tf2 in eager mode you don't have
a graph anymore so you compute gradient
by sort of tracing your operations in
the forward pass and then going back
through your tape to fill your gradient
so the way you use gradient tape is
something like this imagine you have a
tensor X and then you perform a
computation y equals x squared you have
a gradient a plat watch on X and then to
compute the gradient you just call tape
up reading Y with respect to X so by
default we made a design choice and as
soon as you call tape dot gradient we
clear all the resources that are held by
the theater this is for the use for the
most common use case in deep learning
where you have a scalar loss in you
compute your gradient once and then you
don't need those resources anymore but
if that's not the case for your model
you can define a persistent tape by
using persistent equals true and then
you can call gradients as many times and
then you will have to manually clear
your tapes resources by using Python
delete you can also use the tape for
computing higher-order derivatives by
nesting them so in this exam
the inner loop computes your forward
pass and then you compute the first
order derivative in your inner energy
after the gradient table and then the
outer T of that gradient tape is
watching your forward pass and the
gradient you computed so now you can
compute a gradient or this entire
computation to get your second order
derivatives okay so in the previous
examples
I had these manual watch calls but those
are only meant for like non trainable
variable tensors if you have any
variables in your model those are
automatically tracked so if you access
any variable inside of the context of a
TF gradient tape you automatically track
that and you can take gradients with
respect to those so like in this example
you don't have to track the variables
created by your fully connected there's
but in case you don't want to track all
your variables you can pass a special
flag called watch access variables
equals false this will say don't track
my videos by default and I'll tell you
what to track and then you can manually
specify which variables you want to
track okay so in tf2 we have
consolidated on Keros has a top-level
API
this does not mean that we are getting
rid of all our low-level api you still
have access to everything but Cara's
provides a lot of nice things for
example it allows you to track your
variables and provides you a nice
hierarchy to save your models and then
ways to visualize them and things like
that so there are various ways of using
cater so this is the most simple way of
using care as you define sequential
model and then you just add layers in a
sequence or you can define arbitrary
tags of models by creating your input
layers and then you create your
computation to the tag and then you have
your outputs and then towards the end
you create care as that model and then
you specify your inputs and outputs you
can also define custom layers using this
kind of format where you have a build
method which defines your weights and a
call method which defines your
computation so you don't have to always
create your weights in the bill metal
you could do that in the constructor as
well but this is required for cases when
you wear your weights depend on the
put shape which is often the case for
example in dense layers you can also use
a sub classing API where each layer has
multiple sub layers which are
referencing inside it and then if you
need even more functionality you can
suppress model which has additional
methods for fit and compile which is
basically to run a bit to train and and
to do inference on your model so once
you have defined your model which is
like encapsulate your computation and
your weights you use compile and fit
it's a compiled basically you provide
compile your optimizer and and your loss
is already there in the model so
basically it computes your gradient
graph and it prepares your model so that
now you can take you can train it and
then you can do inference over it and
you can use the high-level model of free
tapi which basically performs the
training and it has a bunch of these
useful callback setting that you provide
for example you can provide an early
stopping callback which says hey watch
my validation accuracy and if that
doesn't change for a while the stop
training or you can provide tensor board
which is like tensor floors like
visualization toolkit and then you can
create a callback with a log directly
where you all your summaries and all
your losses will be locked or you can
specify more a checkpointing callback
which would basically periodically
checkpoint your model so that you don't
lose your work if you get preempted and
you can write your own callbacks as well
if you don't want to use the high-level
model that 50 API or say you're not
subclassing TFS model and you're like
just using regular layers or even not
even carers but even lower level
tensorflow api you can use the TF
gradient tape to do your training so you
basically you run your model under the
TF gradient a we compute the gradients
you update your metrics manually and you
can apply a gradient manually as well
okay so I've mentioned about performance
earlier so for making it easy to run
your models in the distributed setting
we have been working on this TF dot
distribute API this comes with a bunch
of distribution strategies which allow
you to basically run your models under
different configurations without
changing your
or too much the one example of a
distribution strategy is this TF
distribute mirror strategy this is used
when you say want to run your model on a
single machine with multiple GPUs and
how this does this is basically
replicates your model and your variables
on each device and then it uses
something called all reduce to basically
keep all your variables in sync so I'll
give you an example of an already sell
girl term so it's a ring reduced
already's algorithm they're like your
GPUs arranging the Rings so in this case
each GPU shares it said it's setup
tensors with the next one in the ring
and then they go around in a loop so in
like two iterations each GPU has all the
tensors from all of the GPU so now they
have full information to compute a
cousin consistent gradient update to
apply to its set of variables I must
also point out that this these already
use algorithms are supposed to be
network efficient so a lot of hardware
vendors provide their own custom
implementations so for example in PF
distribute we use the nickel library
from Nvidia okay so how do you use TF
not distribute say you have your model
code like this you just throw in these
two lines of code to create the mirrored
strategy and you create a context
manager and all of like all of our
layers and caris models are aware of
these contexts and then they make sure
they are replicated in the right place
so you don't have to do anything else
which does the same thing as mirror
strategy but now it allows you to run
multiple cells each of which can have
views
oh pretty much already 10 Oh LTS trading
there like you have a parameter server
where you keep your large weights for
example you're embedding and you want to
do sparse lookups and you don't want to
use a device memory for doing that
there's also deep you strategy but Bruce
will cover that in the next step skipper
okay so here's some things to learn more
I would specially recommend checking out
that TF distributed with custom training
loops example
okay so is it allows you to using this
another way of using like a list of
tensors and it is like serious like your
function will only apply to a particular
slice of your tensor but this is
efficient like this often like single
element computation which are very
expensive this one as you can see if you
have a folder where you do like element
wise multiplication over slices of two
tensors
you can equivalently write it as C
equals a dot B / a where the star is the
element wise multiplication but there
are often much more complicated cases
which are harder to handle and when you
have like a sort of a graph for a single
a bunch of competitions together which
are built for element-wise operations
it's harder to convert this entire thing
into a vast computation another example
is if you're like me and you like like
doing single element gathers and you
just want it to work for a batch of
stuff you can use the a vectorized map
and it works much faster than using TF
math function another place where the
effect tries map has been used is for
computing for example gradients so if
you don't want patch aggregated
gradients and you would rather have for
example variance you can use the airport
vectorized map and in this example which
is very simple to add just one dense
layer TF dot vectorized map is 2x faster
than the earth mass function and this is
not just something experimental we used
here petrus map for computing jacobians
in our gradient tape api okay and yeah i
think so the support for DF vectorized
map is not 100% but it supports getting
a large chunk of es APA so like I think
as I'm making a slide suppose like 200
operations ok so another cool thing is D
F dot custom gradient so this allows you
to specify a custom gradient function
for any Python forward function you have
for example say for any reason you have
a non differentiable forward function FN
but in your backward pass you don't want
to drop your gradient so in that case
you can define this kind of gradient
pass-through function which basically
says just pass my incoming gradients
through instead of dropping them another
example is if you want to recompute your
forward pass when you're doing a
gradient so if you are concerned about
the peak memory usage of your model and
you don't want to keep the activations
from your forward pass
you can define this custom gradient
function which recomputes your power
function when you are doing a derivative
and then uses those activations for the
grading policy you basically have a
trade-off between performance and memory
another pretty useful thing is when you
want to stabilize a gradient so if you
have this example where you have a lot 1
plus X and you take like a naive grading
through this you will end up with an X
code 1 plus X which is which will give
you an an at like even moderately large
values of X so you can rewrite it as a
custom gradient where you say hey it
just have my greedy interview 1 minus 1
over 1 plus X which will not give you
man sand work as expected
ok so another thing we have been working
on is forward mode differentiation so
contrast this with the backward what's
in backward mode you start with the Y's
and then you apply a chain rule
backwards and forward mode you start at
the top we start with tangents or
derivatives with respect to your X's and
then you work downwards so this is not
in the public API here but I think it
will land very soon
this basically computes you Jacobian
vector product instead of your VG piece
and so this is I think this is not very
useful for the regular single loss
neural nets where you just want to
compute the first order derivatives but
if you have like say a function which
has like multiple PI's and a single X or
if you want to compute Hessians or
something this is as efficient as
computing a regular backprop but it
takes much lesser memory because this
this forward propagate security and so
it does not need to keep the
intermediates around and we also have
added TF drops so this is the way of
like directly accessing the low-level
operations that are available in tensor
flow so say you are building a library
and you really care about using certain
operation and you don't want to rely on
TS high-level api which could so about
these low-level operation motherhood you
can directly use T after drops there are
some caveats here I think like you
always need to use keyword arguments and
things like that but you have this
flexibility if you need yeah
and then there's a lot of other stuff
going on like Swift potential flow which
is basically provides you language level
automatic differentiation and has really
nice interrupts with Python and C which
I would I would recommend checking it
out and then there's lot of work going
on in ml ir which is the next-gen ir for
like upcoming hardware and software
platform so machine learning and then
there's tons and tons of other libraries
that have built on top of tensorflow
which really give tensorflow
its meaning and yeah I think a bunch of
these have already moved to tensorflow
too which is really nice okay that's
that's it that's all I had if you're
interested in learning more it has a
couple links to rights and tutorials
which have all been updated to
tensorflow too so please check it out
and if you have any questions concerns
or suggestions please reach out to us on
github.com slash tensorflow thank you
so hi I am Bruce I also work with
Google's pretty enough I'm actually for
mathematician so I kind of moved a long
time ago and now I work on use and GPUs
and I help internal and external teams
sort of move their models from GPUs or
CPUs to keep used and so we're gonna
talk a bit about GPUs today what they're
used for and also are see our program
where you can get free to access and
show you how to get it so ok so here's
our agenda the first thing what are TPU
is right basically GPUs are our own an
acceleration program like a GPU they can
be used for accelerating all your
computations about both their
computations or your ml models and they
were designed from the ground up so to
make basically large-scale training
possible I mean if you look at GPUs GPUs
just happen to be the
harder which seemed to work right for ML
but they weren't designed for a mellow
from the ground up but they were
designed to you know push pixels
together graphics cards people can play
games
it has happened that that worked well
from machine warnings somehow though TPS
were designed to all designed to only do
ml right basically we can do things like
map malls and republican of operations
very fast and we can do them with
multiple machines all communicating
really well very quickly so these are
available now I mean we have some pair
of versions of GPUs which we'll talk
about and they're kind of all available
now by cloud so if you have a lot of
money you can purchase them or you know
if your researcher I say you can get
this free GPUs we offer to try it out
and we hope that you'll use them and and
and give us feedback and so I mean
here's the problem we had right because
Google as a whole was doing a lot of
work on CPUs
basically we were training models and
you're using hundreds of CPUs thousands
of CPUs I think some very large
percentage of google's compute well
spent
you know preparing machine learning
models on CPU and well because of
Moore's law and ending we see that the
speed we get for Lucy Hughes is it's not
increasing at faster was before and so
the choice we had was basically to say
well are our models also get much bigger
as well right if you look here you know
you have our simple models back at 2013
or even older than that and then we have
these new models like our go models you
have open eyes you know dota models
that's open ie right
always very good anyway yeah all these
huge models which we now have billions
of parameters and take you know cutoff
flops a computer a day so in fact our ml
or ml usage is outpacing our CPU growth
this is a big problem right so the
question is how can we get trained
bigger more modern models quickly at a
cost effective
Manor and so that's what basically what
we tried to do we said okay what can we
do we can increase parallelism so they
can train over more machines or we can
increase specialization basically and we
did both of these the teepee use our
answer to both of these we have a
specialized chip it can compute all the
chips can communicate together over a
custom network they're really fast in
that sense and they're also designed for
ml from the ground up so are two types
of chips we have to sort of there's a
lot of designs we have you're going to
ask me why they're called v2 and v3 but
I said there's two of them what happened
to v1 so if we wanted something to talk
about but no v1 is not publicly
available it's an older design it was
one of our first ships with inference
only and so the only thing that we have
internally our v2 and v3 which can be
used both for training and for inference
and so if you look at these sort of
specifications basically one of these
TPU boards here is roughly equivalent to
four GPUs so if these chips is roughly
the cone of a GPU that the cost is about
I would say something like a half or
quarter of the cost so for us it's boy a
more efficient and well so this means
that you have an option now 40 views of
rather than having to go out and buy
like say eight GPUs you want for any
huge model which might cost you I don't
know like $20,000
you can now sort of well pay a fraction
that cost allowed between the same
models and just to have an idea what
this kind of looked like oh I should
have put it back here if you want to
have a lot of great details here
honestly it's the system architecture
for GPUs on our cloud thing or our
website you can see basically a huge
amount of relation about how these
machines put together and how they are
they together you can see pictures of
them in the data center so you can sort
understand physically how they're laid
out and it's I know I think it's pretty
impressive the basic layout of the chips
look to look like this and this
influences kind of some of the designs
of the models or how quickly or what
sort of things you can
models so basically our TPB to check
basically on each of those single chips
there's two computing cores each the
course is one big matrix multiply unit
which can effectively multiply a 128 by
128 sort of point matrix at a time so
this means that effectively the TPU is
designed really around models of 128 so
if you're running a TPU model you can
often actually round up your your your
dense layers or all your all your your
answers like this to muffles 128 for
free so if your so this basically means
that yeah so if you have a small model
you may be only of 64 you're losing it
with the 64 somewhere just double that
128 you'll get you know more more
parameters and like a few time really
won't go up because basically what we're
having to do is if you give us a 64 wide
Ector having to pad up the home 22
together they're kind of wasting wasting
cycles and this keeps you three chip
which is just coming online now in cloud
has more mammal units so it's twice as
fast and also is more memory the more
face clear parameters on the other chips
themselves so I wanted to talk a bit
about how you like how people are using
GPUs nowadays like what what are people
doing so here's three examples of models
which people have trained on diffuse
some internal and external so the first
thing I think what the first one of one
of the first things announced was you
may recall I don't know about six months
ago there was this whole thing or open a
I and after gbq2 model and then they
said hey we can't release this because
it's too powerful and you know people
invite music - I don't know or create
spam on internet but basically I think
it's totally released now finally and we
actually helped them trained our model
on GPUs we used basically 128 chips so
if you look at those computer boards you
saw there that's that's 32 of those
computer boards all networked together
on computers and if we trains John Baum
I think this model had you know billions
of parameters and we use a system in
that case music we
two point zero because we were available
at that point in time but that one we
use something called mesh tensorflow I
measure the flow if you can find
occupational online as a way of sort of
doing model doing model parallelism
rather than data parallelism when you're
training on multiple multiple I'm what
war machine another example more
recently announced was we do some work
with the Mayo Clinic and so Mayo Clinic
is pretty interested in picking models
where you have these giant
three-dimensional images from CT scans
so I mean Giants FEMA seems small you
think 256 but 56 bit key statistics that
seem that high resolution but for them
not pretty huge prior to this when they
were undergoing GPUs they could only
train their image segmentation bottles
on 128 by 128 by 128 images and so by
still up on 50 pews we were able to give
them a model with trained faster than
GPUs trained on larger images got better
accuracy because of that because the
more images so you can you can see more
and and it was cheaper from the train so
the confidence of win/win/win you got a
more accurate models you have more
parameters it rains faster and a cheaper
train so for them they were kind of
really happy with this and moreover to
say we've even actually pushed this even
further even further we've pushed this I
mean actually dimension train bottles on
512 by 512 by 512 images so those are
actually contacting a large and think
about the amount of memory each image
takes all right so there became this
model using a batches of 1 but it's like
you can get around dad that's yeah as
another example of let's say of large
bottles was this model Bert which maybe
you might have heard of it's some months
ago from Google researchers specifically
designed around he use the model
architecture was designed to say this is
slow it works volunteers this works fast
on GPUs and we got basically you know
a good model which trained really
quickly and I mean now so far we can
actually clean this entire model in 76
minutes so it's it's it's we've got the
train come down really huge amount by
using CPUs by using these large scale
keep you computations and as an aside I
think we noticed we look to be at the
the paper submissions I think from I
clear and we think that's like 200
papers we've been burnt like why there's
so many variations we don't understand
people seem to love this I don't know
why another thing we do is because we
know there's problems right GPUs but I
say okay you know sure the Guru tutorial
assembly tells you I can run em missed
on a TPU congratulations you know there
are of course we know you convinced
about simple moles on GPUs right how do
you actually run complicated evolve on
GPUs so we've actually made our goal for
ourselves on github to provide you a a
wide range of free sort of models which
in 2.0 which work and pain basically at
the same speeds what models do or even
faster and we can sort of use those if
you are interested as a sort of basis
for your own models you can take one of
these model check it out rip out the
internal code and plug your own thing in
or modify them your add layers but so
far we have is okay we have we have Bert
you have transformer model Jennifer for
model excel on that a ResNet and
initiative once again Emma kukësi them
list I but these are all working right
now in 2.0 on GPUs if you run them and
moreover we're going to basically have
this repository more models like
DBT 2 and more image which models like
the sufficient and I match that and
other models for this we're just gonna
keep on updating this as new models come
in because they want to provide you guys
with some examples of what you can do
with GPUs so I want to come do a brief
discussion about how you can actually
use GPUs with teeth 2.0 so the basic
idea is going to be around the side
of distribution strategies which earlier
so what's gonna happen is what you do is
you're gonna log in to the Google Cloud
II once you have your freaky beus you'll
log into the Google cloud website you
offer the cloud console you'll type in
this CTP you up as I say yes version
nightly to get the latest but all this
bug fixes generally should work but
sometimes sometimes that might be busted
we apologize though that happens but
generally it should work properly and so
our voice has to use distribution
strategies and the idea of the trypsin
strategies is that the same code is
supposed to work on CPUs on GPUs and
CPUs all you have to do is swap out the
strategy so in this case what I'm doing
is I'm treating mental things are still
in flux but basically you create one of
these objects if you look at the
tutorials online for cloud to tell you
how to create one of these you look at
the code that we saw earlier you do you
create any metrics you want in the scope
of the strategy and then basically
anything you do as model will run on a
TPU and you know the next big difference
is that when using just when you're
using distributed data we generally
advise you to use these TF data data
sets API because it helps us understand
our API understand why our data looks
like and what for operations you're
applying to it
and with that we can then take your
piece of data and we can split it out
and make your dataset run on all the
individual machines but you haven't keep
used because what was actually happening
behind the scenes here just as you saw
that that that tray that PCB with those
big fans and radiators from those forty
few chips on it each of those is
connected to an actual physical machine
and so effectively we have to run a copy
of this data set on a physical machine
push machine on the CPU and
they said do all the CPU operations
which are necessary to say process that
data said all that past the Nativity be
you know this as you defined it and then
essentially instantiate it remotely or
all different machines which had a few
pews on them and so what you do is you
then you create an iterator from that
and now you have this thing which we
call a distributed data set you also had
to find your loss you don't have to do
this inside the scope so all the stuff
here is outside the scope I had here is
with strategy does scope all you have to
do is to find these three things that
scope your metrics your optimizer and
your model itself everything else can be
defined outside of the scope if you want
so you know to worry too much about that
the one thing we're going to note here
is that we're gonna read advise you to
use a custom frame that's what I'll talk
about in a moment
if the custom training loop we've made
some decisions with it with the API
which might be a little different from
what you're expecting version one did
give person one we need distributed
training or something like keep us to
meet her it would always take your loss
and divide it by the global batch size
so you got the average loss of your
global batch in with these custom
created loops in 52 we've made the
decision that you have a control so
because the other control gets remember
to divide your loss a little batch size
that's one one caveat that people have
found a little knowing and moving from
PRP 130ft to so this is basically what a
custom frame that looks like what we're
gonna find we're going to find a single
function which trains a single step and
what we do is we call training step with
this decorator called TF function what
does TF function do TF function tells
tell Spencer flow that you're
dysfunction is actually a graph so you
first see every function in Python but
then tensorflow traces of this function
I produced a draft behind scenes to
actually arriving and we need to do that
because we need to have somehow transmit
your function to all the other machines
which IP fuse on them and run the run it
and it's just much easier to make a
graph which is what understands Nayland
come here function and then transmit
that instead and so inside this training
step what we have is we have a secondary
function this is what we call barred by
GPU step so it's hard to see here I
apologize for the color of the comment
but basically everything you step
function so it's going to be a run on
the GPU so anything outside of it will
go out on the CPU and everything inside
or another GPU and so we do the exact
same there are things that were talked
about earlier with 2.0 you take your
inputs from the model you take your
gradient cake if you're the model
function all those inputs - how could
you keep your loss and you have your
ingredients you applied optimizer and
then let's say I have a metric here for
my loss after my metrics by loss and the
key thing here is lot statement here the
last name of the function
experimental run v2 that actually was
that's actually runs your function on
the GPU or if you're gonna do a strategy
like if you're in a marriage strategy
from what's your work admire strategy or
the parameters for a strategy the same
thing applies so the thing that you have
inside that internal step function
they're calling the experimental run v2
that part is what runs inside the
strategy or runs remotely and all the
machines everything outside of that it's
just running on your local your local
machine which is running your Python
code okay so that's what you're look
like you know what do you do well this
is what you do you just run that step
many times you run out football times
you pass in whoops I there's a typo
there I forgot to actually pass the data
into the training step let's see did I
yes I did okay I supposed to pass the
iterator in one of those records I could
just distribute iterator I supposed to
pass dad in good here in the to the
training staff I apologize these things
happen I guess and epic well wonderful
so and you can print out your epics and
basically this training loop is running
on your host machine but it's
dispatching the off of the graph to run
on their able to be used
instantaneously as you're running it and
then it's only actually when we
when we actually ask you this value of
this so what you'll notice we try to do
this is these steps alone will run
really fast in fact they'll run so fast
unbelievable because they're getting
executed asynchronously we
asynchronously dispatched these that
keep you complications and the annoyance
is that you will have the final
statement you'll stop it'll pause until
against the values back or the training
loss and then output them so just a word
of warning don't time if you're using
keep users people are 0 you don't want
to time their training steps by putting
a let's say timer around each step
because it will be very useful what you
want to do is you want to you want to
put a time around the the the outer loop
and then divide by the number of steps
because basically a little block getting
be the key execution will block until
you get there is all that okay that's
pretty simple I want to get some general
advice about tip use and things to avoid
or things that make you slow because of
course there's things that make uslaugh
right so things you want to avoid our
tensors are changed shape each each
batch we technically support this but
what's gonna happen is you will be
forced on what's called a recompilation
and a retracing of your of your step
function every step or your batch size
changes so this will put a huge overhead
which you do what a pair so if TP you
generally want to keep your back your
gear decides your cancers the same free
step the other thing you generally want
to avoid inside that TPU function all
right all right you step or things which
print or deal with strings or write your
files things are kinda or natively
like you would think run on a custom
piece of hardware like you know you can
avoid this you can actually enable this
thing called soft placement and we want
actually dig into your graph those
functions which don't run into your
place want to see if you again except
this is slow so you will notice a big
speed hit if you try to enable this and
prints in the middle of you're in the
middle here in the middle of year
understand now I'll point out that the
way kind of around this if you're
debugging things is to do one of two
things it's to either run a few strategy
I knew that converge strategy or on a
CPU because then you can
and you do all your noble let's say
print debugging you better do to make
sure our models be hitting correctly or
what you can do actually is you can
actually return anything from these
functions so I can return something for
my GPU step and then it'll be the return
value of this experiment already - and
then I can return that for my training
step and then I would see that value
here on my host where I was running so
you can return values and another way of
inspecting your model expect expecting
the stuff which is being run on GPU and
as I mentioned before GPU is generally
preferable if you're multiples of 128 so
you almost often really able to round up
on this one of your dimensions there go
most 128 yes very good okay so yes so
there's two things there's two options
with high writers or 250 film is 2.0 you
either can set the soft placement or you
can return your summary from the inner
step and write it after the experiment
of you to call so you're just writing it
on the CPU that's that's that's nice too
we kind of handled that for you behind
the scenes often with this cheap UF's
meter which is the v1 API whereas with
the v2 API you do a little more this
work yourself but yeah you just you just
you can either do this soft placement
and it works
we definitely have models internally
which use this I'm trained and trained
fine you just expect a small slow down
due to the transfer back and you also
don't worry like another thing is to
worry about with GPUs if you're gonna do
these sort of things is are you transfer
all the sensors back to the central
machine which is running or are you
running it like so there's some inherent
problem because let's say you have a
hundred machine hundred physical hosts
running this program and now you're all
the tens are backward and you want refer
back to the host which is running the
Python program you now have to incur the
cost of the entire data transfer back
that host so sometimes you can do tricks
like for instance only to transfer back
to some way from host:10
and that gets your summary and is much
faster than getting it from all the
holes so some general some general
advice here there's information on the
TFR see it's this type of loci of our
sieve gonna learn more about it
if you want more than just those those
three five GPUs that we're offering with
the Emilia code you can actually apply
if a larger project combined you can
apply to this program and they will if
you succeed they can give you maybe
hundreds of GPUs if you have some large
model that you have some huge is on a
trail but our advice is that is to get a
get some experience with the free TP use
about the middle code first to see how
they work with your setup you know and
you want to program them and before you
maybe apply for this a larger grant and
in general other garbage that clarity
views and of course our github with our
models and I guess the custom random
stuff which was already mentioned I
mentioned earlier so I have a few more
minutes
are there any to the questions well I'll
first enter things later and you know if
you want to answer runoff questions you
know everybody you have the ask them as
well yes hi everyone sorry for the small
today's think we are ready to get
started on your previous presentations
are an introduction to and I want to
share with you how this can accelerate
our research with a concrete example so
I'm wisdom and I'm here to Mira I've
been using tensorflow for the past two
and Tipu's for the past year as
beneficiary of the tee at our C program
these are the top things there are
things make sense of the critical
research the fact that we have eg
execution enabled by default which means
we can inspect and attack things but we
can still use graph because the provides
P the ability and make your model
fast and ready for deployment to
to the cloud to the device and even on
the web and also because of that tight
integration with Paris an API for
machine learning so I'll be are
presenting terms of flow to go from a PI
touch perspective because I am aware
that most of us here at Mira aspire
torch so draw some balance between turns
over 2005 church or research and
consider simple task of video question
answering I'll show how we can
distribute training on cloud GPUs and
show you some public resources for
researchers so cameras is a simple API
that runs on top of many frameworks
including tensor flow piano and so on
it's known for its dead simplicity in
the past versions did this came at a
cost of flexibility simple for the
beginners but hard to customize for
researchers like us and the community
was divided between tensor flow one that
X users that wanted that full
flexibility and customize the layers and
using the previous cares API for simple
feed-forward parallel but now both tiers
affluent classes have improved a lot and
Clara's now provides as presented in the
previous presentations three styles or
creating our models so the sequential
for our simple feed for neural networks
of single input and single output the
functional API which appears very simple
is powerful enough for most of our use
cases from my experience and it's very
fun that you can use it to compose any
arbitrary graph topologies you want and
obviously you can subclass a model
implement your constructor and your
custom forward pass so with that
tightened integration you seek in the
benefit of tensor flow as that robust
and flexible model but you can think of
in us with now a cleaner API on top of
it
and it's good that Kyra's is now the
default high-level API for 20 models
with density so it's now the time to
draw some powers comparisons between
sets off to that one by touch so that's
how you declare tensors of by church and
that's how you would do it for tensor
flow so these are the basics and so
those tensors are constant so the way
you will want to declare immutable
things you're like the weight of a grant
network for instance would be by using
TF dot variable so this tells tensorflow
that this variable would change states
across let's say the training free model
and it's exposes some operations like
assigning the new value adding from that
value adding to that value was
subtracting from it's as you would do
for instance in a training update of
Socastee gradient descent so the
previous slides already showed how to
compute gradient using tensor flow so
I'm not gonna repeat it so this is for
instance how you would do it with
fighters this is a concrete example with
the cross-entropy laws that clear enough
did I increase it all right all right so
here we compute the loss and with the
backward pass the gradient is available
here so that's how you would do it with
terms of flow you alternate a started
watching variables and outside of the
tape you can retrieve the gradients of
that loss with respect to this variable
alright so I prepared a very simple
example we can use to illustrate this
and this will be task of video question
answering where you have a video a
sequence of frames and then a question
and we would like to implement a model
that can
produce a probability distribution of
other possible answers the question we
keep in the video so the architecture
can look like this so we have a sequence
of frames and we can use a CNN to
extract the visual features from them
and what are the sequence using an ALICE
IAM and the question is a sequence of
tokens so obviously we will need to
retrieve the word embeddings and use an
error cm tomorrow to have a summary of
the question and you can concatenate
them and have a couple of dense layers
on the top to classify so obviously we
are researchers and there are many ways
we can complicate this so here for
instance rather than having an LCM I can
if ma CNN is a preacher in ResNet for
instance take the last average pooling
layer and I have another pooling on top
of it since the sequence of frames can
be abitt very very large I can also
combine only the early and final frames
and for the question I can also use a
transformer rather than valium and there
are also many ways I can use a be
directional a TCM here as well right
I can also use a female Raider
that would take the question baiting us
inputs and generate the gamma beta
values that we can use to modulate the
CNN visual feature Maps and since the
last average pulling layer of the model
like resonance questions will reach on
vectors here so here we have a sequence
of vectors we can use this as the query
of an attention model also to attend to
to these features but for the sake of
this demo I will stick with this simple
architecture and here I will show you
how you can quickly implement that in
collab how many of you know call app and
use it all right that's great so here I
import
president Malo from chaos so that's
where i instr shear it and I'm
retrieving preacher in wait on image
names I think it's already downloaded so
it won't take much time and in this
particular case I don't want to rejoin
the CNN model so I can mark it as not
trainable and so the input to this
resident model is supposed to be a batch
and the dimension of each frame but here
we have the sequence right this is the
number of frames we have so one three
can be to multiply to combine these two
axis the batch and the sequence length
here and give it to the CNN and reshape
the tensor later but another way you can
quickly do it also is by using a time
distributed wrapper which will apply
which will give this independently to
the CNN for each of the time steps so
the term distributed would take this
axis by default as the time axis and
this is good for us so on top of the
frame features we implement a be
directional elysium and you can see this
is the shape of the features so
resonates returns a vector of this size
and we have 128 of them and this is the
output after the error slim this is
because it's a bit Direction also we are
concatenating the outputs the hidden
state from both directions and that's
how we process the question so the
question is a sequence of integer
indices corresponding to the tokens in
the vocabulary and obviously we'll have
an embedding layer and so this
vocabulary size and the dimension of
each embedding and a be directional lsdm
on top of its to return a picture of the
sides so that's where you combine both
and obviously on top of that you have
some a couple of dense layers I like how
you can quickly mention and activation
inside us rather than using for instance
composing a new layer as we did by
Church and that's how you would be the
model so we instantiate it and this
model here since we are using the
functional API knows that we have two
components one for the question
and one for the video and know that we
expect that we have to give to import
right
and here we combine it by mentioning we
compile it by specifying the optimizer
Dallas so if I have disconnected because
I didn't run some parts of this
right
yes I should have taken a simpler model
again fully yeah it's compact great
though this is the summer of the model
the different layers we have and we can
see the number of trainable parameters
and I like this utility function that's
lots graph of the model so you can see
here that's the section for the video
question
I'm distributed layer here the LCM and
so on and we have the dense layers so
that's a summary of this model and a
summation previously we use the function
of the functional API so that's how the
code looks like but obviously we can
also subclass as I said before in my use
case as the functional API can respond
to you most of our use cases of
researchers but you can also subclass as
we do in fighters one mistake people
coming from fighters usually do one
migrating to tensorflow
is to extend TF crested model for each
block because the word toda that was the
equivalent to an end dot module now this
is not true in fact Chancellor has a TF
dot module class which is the base class
for neural networks and the Kira's
extend is with EF dot K rest of layers
that layer or blocks that and other
models and we also have to have those
pairs that model for a single model that
would take some inputs and returned and
outputs so for building blocks that are
now the final model you should extend
layers of layer this is the same code as
before but now with the sub classing API
so we have this video model that is the
CNN and RNN and this is how we implement
your custom forward loop forward pass
we have the same for the question model
which is also an extension of a layer
because it just block beside our model
and the MLP with one hidden layer and
the softmax layer and that's the model
that is the Curris model that takes the
inputs and that instantiate both models
and this is what the four paths look
like so obviously I can also go ahead
and compile this model alright
but we can compare it as we did before
with the functional API so I want to go
ahead and trim the smaller so for that
I'm generating fake data so this is the
back size there are frames and dimension
of each frame I'm sampling from random
our uniform distribution the pixels and
this is the question so just some fake
data for training and I can start
training with the feets
function so where we go okay
all right
yeah but there was a little
all right so the model should be
training now go back to the slide for
the next section yeah it started
training him all right so that's beer I
was because you can see in color as you
already know that you can select a
runtime and this was a GPU runtime so I
was training here I'm training on one
GPU I can stop the train I'm training a
one GPU but obviously the goal of this
is to show how we can distribute this
two GPUs so the previous talks already
covered the difference distribution
strategies and TF w --t is what I'm most
excited about with tensorflow 2.0
because I was one of those that use the
estimator and god they were hard to use
and difficult to to develop as well so
it's now cool that with just a
distribution strategy you can distribute
to different platforms including GPS
entities so that how the same code in
one for instance on many GPU you've
already heard about a mirror strategy
which is you have a node and multiple
GPUs and each variables of your model
will be duplicated across each of the
nodes so each node computer forward
paths send back the loss we update the
variables and replicates those variables
to each node so we just specify the
strategy here and we should define and
compare the model inside the strategy
just tells the distal stencil flow that
this model variable should be replicated
across each of the GPU nodes and this
model compiled inside the strategy means
tells this optimizer that it will have
to aggregate gradients from different
notes but important to have them inside
Stratos code so with that you can
we can do the same thing as before and
you can model the feets outside of the
Stratus cup so we have already specified
that this would be a distributed
training and we can just start bidding
all right
so and now I also want to show you how
you can train isn't abused and have
another notebook for this so two
training tip use we need to as shown you
just the previous talk implements a
custom training step this is the
function that computes the loss this is
the lab object we initiate some metrics
and this is a training step for each
core of the tip you not it's called it's
cheap its EPO chip will compute this
training step and we open up a gradient
computer model and exceed from the the
table get a gradient after loss with
respect to the model trainable variables
and we use those gradients to update the
model variables based on this optimizer
and so that was the code that runs on
each CPU chip and that's the code that
tells the motor to st. the training
instruction to each of them so you do
that with this experimental function so
we specify the training step the
distributed data sets and we also
specify the reduce operator to use to
aggregate the losses so now we create
inside the TPU strategy I have to
mention that this TP strategy was
created so you would want to do it's at
the start of your program because this e
resists the memory of the GPU so here we
are connecting to the cars if you
cluster to achieve the tip you
and in order to use this as change one
time ya have to specify that CP actually
rather here so that can train you
directly inside collab and this is Bala
pre codes to initialize and connect to
the CPU and that's where we instantiates
the tip your strategy though this was
created on top of the codes this is the
same code and now inside this deeper
strategy we can implement a custom
training loop as we often do in Python
and in part re and iterate over data
sets and call the distributor training
step you would also notice that a
specificity of that function decorator
because this does a heavy workload and I
would like to to compare it and optimize
it so what this you can observe up to
three or four four times Peter as
compared to you with the execution so
that's it for training on TPU I'm not
gonna run this because of time and the
last thing I wanted to share with you is
some public resources for ARS
researchers so everybody loves preacher
in weight right so you can go to TF hub
to get access to some free training
models and I'm also very excited about
tensile float datasets which is a
collection of more than 100 I check
yesterday pre-processed common data sets
we use both for language modeling object
detection and many tasks till you would
like to use this and these are some
resources to get sort of tensor 200 for
researchers I use some of these to
prepare the slides yeah thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Anne I'm a
software engineer at Google and here to
talk about
tensorflow Jess so specifically I'm
gonna try to cover three topics which is
one why would you want to do machine
learning with JavaScript - why you would
want to use tensorflow j/s to do machine
learning with JavaScript and finally
three how people today are using pencil
flow so why would you want to do machine
learning with JavaScript it's true that
there already exists
very mature tools for doing machine
learning other languages like Python but
JavaScript offers some unique advantages
over these other languages and to try to
make that case I want to show you this
video of an interactive google doodle
which was featured last march in honor
of composer jay s box 330 fourth
birthday
on that day if you went to google.com
you would have seen some empty staff
lines inviting you to compose a simple
melody and once you did the doodle would
create a harmony to go with your melody
resulting in a mini box style chorale
behind the scenes we were sending each
user's composition through a neural
network that generates harmonizing
voices based on a seed melody and if the
users device was powerful enough and so
this is why I'm showing you this video
if the users device was powerful enough
we would actually run that inference on
the client using tensorflow j/s all in
all that day tensorflow jeaious
generated approximately 30 million
pieces of music and not only was it just
cool for us to see our library being
used by so many people
Google was actually also able to save
significant server resources that day by
pushing model execution to the client
which brings me to the first reason for
using javascript for machine learning is
uses server side costs
and also by saving that round-trip to
the server there is potential for
reducing another advantage of running
your models client-side is that it
better protects user privacy suppose you
have a model that makes medical
diagnosis based on user images if that
model can run entirely on the client
then those user images never have to
leave the browser or suppose you have a
text-based model that analyzes a user's
newsfeed in order to suggest relevant
content users might appreciate not
having to send what they're reading to
your server for analysis the other
advantage of running your models in a
browser is that there's nothing to
install oh sorry
actually yeah there's nothing to install
running a model can be as simple as
opening a web page this makes it
possible for your models to reach a much
bigger audience also if your model runs
in a browser that means it can access
things like the devices camera
microphone sensors and other
capabilities through standard Web API s
finally if you're working on an
application that has any sort of web
front-end then you might as well use
JavaScript for model execution if it's
possible so so what is pencil pledge is
tensorflow j/s is an open-source library
we've built for people to deploy retrain
and author models using javascript the
api includes everything from lola ops
such as matrix multiplication or
normalization as well as high-level
Kerris like constructs which we call
layer we also offer a library of
pre-trained models for common tasks
including image classification object
detection pose detection speech
detection and text classification these
models are small fast and ready to be
used in any webpage with just a few
lines of code
so as you can tell by the name tensor
pledge is is part of the tensorflow
eco system and this diagram presents one
way to think about how all the different
components of tensorflow fit together so
if you already use tensorflow Python and
think of pencil ojs as deployment target
so you might author your model in Python
and then use tensorflow j/s to execute
it in a browser or in we have a
converter that we built for this common
use case our converter takes tends to
close save models or Kerris models and
converts them for consumption by Tesla
ojs now I just want to note that as a
deployment target tensorflow j/s of
course works within browsers and node
but we've also built custom integrations
with native platforms such as WeChat
react native and electron so before we
get into some of the ways people are
using tensorflow GIS I want to talk
about our performance we know
performance is top of mind for ml
application developers and for that
reason we've worked hard to make our
library competitive with native
solutions like TF light this diagram has
some numbers for once or representative
model mobile net B 2 you can see that
tensorflow Jas is comparable to TF light
for MacBooks and iPhones for a
client-side inference for server-side
development tensorflow Jas actually has
roughly the same performance
characteristics as tensorflow and that's
because our node back in for words I
speak execution to tensorflow
which means that under the hood we're
able to take advantage of the same
performance that you might be used to if
you already work with tensorflow Python
and I also want to note that these
numbers should only improve we've been
investing heavily in new technologies
such as web GPU which bring computers to
the web as well as was own which
promises near native performance for
JavaScript we've published experimental
backends using these technologies and
we're actively evolving them in
collaboration with
open-source contributors as well as
teams from chrome and oh man well
there's a so this is a supposed to be a
screencap of one of our WeChat apps
working I'll just describe it to you
guys so I want to talk about some of the
ways that people are using tensorflow
just today this application by l'oréal
lets users virtually try on L'Oreal
products such as different shades of
lipstick before purchasing them through
the app the app uses lightweight facial
landmark detection model that runs on
tensorflow j/s and the way it works is
the user can press different colors of
lipstick which you can sort of see and
the lipstick will apply itself to the
user's lips on the screen and I just
think it's a cool example of how running
a model on device can make for a really
nice user experience next I want to talk
about how air B&B is using tensorflow
Jas as part of their onboarding
experience for new users so when you
create an account with Airbnb you need
to upload a profile picture and
sometimes people will upload something
like a passport or which might contain
sensitive information that the user
wouldn't actually want shown to the
world so to solve this problem
engineers at Airbnb trained a model to
recognize government IDs they converted
the model to run intensive ojs and they
baked it into their new user signup flow
and this is just another example of how
running a model can integrate within a
nice user experience I want to talk
about some of the ways that people in
the machine learning research community
are using tensorflow Jas and we really
love these use cases because tensorflow
jeaious actually grew out of a research
project in trying to tie together the
experience of model development more
closely with the experience of model
visualization all introspection so in
this screen cap
you would have seen a web application
that was developed by some researchers
on art which is a hugely popular
language model that's increasingly
prevalent and predictive systems and the
way it works is BER produces these
massive vector write vectors to
characterize pieces of language and our
team developed a tool to look at how
these vectors change given perturbations
of the input text so we put four we
ranbir it through our converter and
shift it into this web application using
pencil ojs inference takes around 150
milliseconds which is not real time but
it's pretty cool to be able to
arbitrarily change a piece of input text
and see how the vectors update and what
I think it points to is that that tenth
apologist has the potential to power
sort of a new class of interactive model
introspection tools
so here's another example this
application is called manifold
and this is a web app that was developed
at uber research for comparing model
performance manifold is designed for ml
researchers who want to understand the
trade-offs in adopting one particular
model over and the way it works is by
clustering the predictions of different
models and showing the user how these
clusterings compare manifold uses
tensorflow js4 k-means clustering and
for competing comparison stats between
models and I think this is just another
cool example of doing things in the
browser that you might naturally think
to do with Python and finally I just
want to highlight the potential ojs
community we launched the library about
a year and a half ago and since then
we've seen significant adoption among
JavaScript developers and ml
practitioners we're lucky to be working
alongside an active community of
open-source contributors to continuously
be improving the library and we've also
been excited to see a number of projects
build on top of our library such as base
API Jas which detects spatial boundaries
as well as ml5 which teaches machine
learning active browser exercises and
that's it here's some links to learn
more thank you so much and anyone has
any questions I'll take them otherwise
Joseph Cohen who's a postdoc at the
University of Montreal will talk to you
next about his research and some of the
ways he's using Tesla Jess Thanks
thank you for joining today so I'm gonna
talk about Mystics rays we look at the
diagnostic pipeline in a hospital we can
see that some patient comes in they get
they get an exam some visualization
happens and then some expert renders an
opinion that that could lead towards the
diagnosis or mates it makes a diagnosis
based on evidence from some
visualization of an x-ray perhaps and
then this goes on to you know form a
cycle of treating the patient so this
detect classified component is where AI
stands to make a lot of ground and
improve healthcare though in the past
Durbin tools that kind of help here and
this is this KD RI so it's like a kidney
donor risk index and this is a tool
that's been around for a long time this
is it was online on this date but it's
existed for a while as a model that you
can you can run like a computational
model to assist in your decision right
but now it's on the web there's a the
Framingham Heart Study as a risk
calculator for your cardiovascular risk
which is now online so doctors can use
it to aid in their diagnosis right so it
just makes sense for the next step to be
justice for a diagnosis is kind of like
a calculator to analyze the radiological
findings in an x-ray okay so where is
this useful it's this emergency room so
in the emergency room you have time
limited humans there where and I can you
can just kind of use computational
resources instead of people time to not
miss anything we can reduce errors and
deal with like fatigue doctors that
don't want to make mistakes and kind of
you know not miss anything you can also
use this in rural hospitals this if we
had this kind of calculator where you're
so far away from radiologists kind of
getting the knowledge of a radiologist
to those areas is very difficult and
maybe there's not a lot of in that
region there's not a lot of resources
for radiologists right so they just
can't have a bunch of remote
radiologists they have to use automation
and fill the gap
is missing need also rare diseases this
is something that we this project is not
doing yet because we need more data but
very rare diseases where doctors are
puzzled this is where a tool would help
them find those those like weird
features in the images that could be
indicative of some diseases also
triaging so you can have people that
aren't there are not doctors triage in
cases that a doctor will see right so
that the most complicated cases or most
dangerous cases are seen first and this
can be done with someone just utilizing
this tool and because every patient is
still going to be viewed by a doctor you
don't really have you know have a risk
of someone who isn't trained doing this
so you can spread out the workload right
is the knowledge can be encapsulated in
this tool instead of just the doctor so
this project has been called nice by
amico so uh so this this project calls
Chester it's a funny name visits it's a
chest and then it's a person so this is
a web delivered tool right so all the
code is delivered via the web browser
right so everything is flat files on a
server which makes scaling this almost
zero cost right because it's just flat
files that can be cached and then all
the computation happens in the browser
all right so no data gets sent right I
mean I guess you this is attentively ojs
kind of talk so this is the this is the
goal of this so which is important for
patient patient privacy right because a
doctor can't just felt like a lot of
overhead but if they if it never leaves
the hospital right then there's no issue
but getting software installed in the
hospital is a pain and in this case it's
just a web browser so there is no
installation it's just running it
alright so we really hit all these pain
points and make this thing like a viable
vector for using these tools where kind
of a lot of other stuff gets in the way
of radiologists and doctors getting
exposure to deep learning tools right
and then a big piece of this that it
wasn't really accounted if you talk
about deployments is I will higher
detection which I go over it in a bit
but
we want to avoid you know processing
image of images of cats all right this
is a someone puts one in and we can't
give it a we can't find that it has a
lung nodule that would that would Road
the confidence the doctor would have in
these tools right so we really need to
calibrate them or the domain that
they're gonna be operating in okay so we
want to make free tools for everyone
we want to let medical professionals
experiment with these tools but just
bypassing all the red tape show the
potential of open data so this was done
using data from the NIH which is
completely open there's no paperwork
that we have to do for like two years at
a time and waiting for approval it's
just a data set you can just get and
work with right so this is this is what
works for deep learning and if deep
learning is gonna work in health care we
need to have a way to encourage deep
learning is the like so you have a way
to encourage that open data is the way
to go if you want to see results right
good and also you can use this tool to
teach radiology and it's probably also a
bunch of other use cases that we haven't
thought of great so we want to bridge
this divide there's a doctors and then
there are deep learning researchers at
Mila and they're really far away and no
one in somewhere in the middle we expect
some magic to happen and make the
researchers develop things that the
doctors need right and I think the
classic paradigm people fall to is is
having companies fill this need but it
seems like that's not working fast
enough we should have just have
researchers talk directly to doctors in
a way that they can do great so okay so
now some potential OGS slides right so
the technical kind of piece of this
which I'm not going to go into much
detail but we need to run dense net in
the browser right and we need it compute
it in like one second
all right although it takes 12 seconds
for an initial run and then one second
for each subsequent round of the model
but we can do that with insanity is out
of distribution detection right so we
played with a lot of different
techniques it turns out that
auto-encoders are just artists awesome
but if you meant them with a sim score
right so it's a structured image
similarity this allows us to perform
this this task of rejecting you know cat
pictures and pictures of knees
pretty effectively but there's still a
lot of research to do there all right so
we also want to do visualization so this
tool will show you a salience in MATLAB
where the model predicted use like which
pixels were used in the prediction right
so we could do that by shipping like
another model that just specifically
computes the gradients for a prediction
but that's that's annoying and maybe not
as versatile and then we have to ship
more weights to the client because is
here actually shipping a hundred and
fifty megabytes of weights to the
clients browser
and then hoping that everything caches
properly so they can use this we don't
want to ship too much so if we could
just so why send special models when we
can just use auto different browser
right so we could compute you the
gradients right in the browser and make
this whole big computation graph and
it's all right in the browser so it
saves a lot of network bandwidth but
also lets us do more versatile things if
you want to visualize just specific
diseases instead of just uh like having
one model that predicts one Grady map we
can have different kind of configuration
so we have a lot more freedom do better
better visualizations okay so I'll go
over some feedback real quick so this is
the kind of use of this so it's spiked
with some articles and then we have kind
of a constant usage at about a hundred
and fifty users a week when they spend
like about three minutes on the site so
it's like they're really people are
using this thing there's been a lot of
confrontation on Twitter I guess there
are people that really like this and
they're like oh this is this is amazing
we're seeing the future and then some
other people that say like I thought
this you know this stuff makes mistakes
sometimes therefore we can't trust it
right and it does make mistakes but this
is the state of the art and it's just
okay but it's not even that so this is
the this is where we are in research in
so there's no there's not some magic
silver bullet and like research that
it's going to be released right this is
we took the state of the art model and
put it here
so if doctors don't like it then we need
to do research we do more research to
make this thing better or that's just
the maximal amount of information that's
in the image right so we need to have
this discussion more okay so there's a
bunch of articles from all over the
world great sort of like
Japan great so the most hype article had
this title and it's a good article but
it kind of positioned it in a wrong way
that says that we're we're like the
whole thing is gonna read x-rays better
than doctors we're the only research
paper says that this model and it's not
even the one meat we evaluated does
better in pneumonia prediction when
compared directly against doctors so
people have contention about the
specific study but in general this is
not true we have a long way to go a long
way to go there okay so it's a good
feedback so this is like shock a lot of
people and this is kind of the stuff we
want that people are able to use this
and they see it work they know the
limits they understand what it can do
they get to learn what the errors are
that it's gonna make right so this is
important so there's been in a bunch of
studies this is a contributed x-rays
from a hospital in Japan where they
looked at the performance prediction on
cases that they had kind of studied the
use of this and this is exactly the
outcome that we wanted there's another
in-depth study here where they kind of
really go in-depth on specific tasks
right so they want to study diffusion so
they look at an image that has a fusion
in it and then see how well the model
can predict this right and they find
that it works really well in some cases
it doesn't work as well in other cases
and there's a good discussion in this
article about like the labels that were
actually using right that we're defined
by the NIH they might not be the right
separation that people would agree on
right so sometimes people think they
should just be the same label you can't
tell them apart or they should be
separate separate labels right so this
actually varies between hospitals and
it's like the opinions of hospitals on
what our diseases kind of are kind of
might be a roadblock in deploying
medical technology into these hospitals
great so want to think
the source code is online here the
system is there and I think every people
everybody
maybe people are in this room who helped
make this possible and nothing
[Applause]
Christians
so it's like 110,000 x-rays from about
30,000 patients multi huh
yeah so we have 0 or all of 14 diseases
of 14 radiological findings yeah
shouldn't I torch because like they the
the dense net model that is like the
state of the our model is was using high
search we'd play around with in a PI
torch and then we can kind of convert it
through on extensive flow and then
deploy yeah so the framework that we
have developed like in there there's a
bunch of conversion utilities so you
could take something from from Charis
and you can already do that you can take
any any any library they can go through
onyx can like spit out a model at this
this framework will use and put into a
browser and run like this and then
compute gradients so what kind of what
you throw in and we bust all these
different configurations alright how's
it going everybody that is super loud
okay great quietly how's it going I'm
Josh from the tensorflow team this will
be really quick I just want to maybe
take 15 minutes and summarize some of
the things that have been said today and
point you to a few useful code examples
that I hope will be helpful to you and
before we get into that I just wanted to
say a few words about tensor flow Jas
because we just saw two really awesome
talks from N and Joseph and if you're
not already convinced that ml on the web
is maybe the way of the future
I just want to show you a few awesome
demos live that really helped convince
me this was the way forward and the
reason I wanted to talk about this is
when I first heard about tensor flow Jas
I was totally wrong about it when I
heard the idea I was thinking like great
like okay we're running machine learning
JavaScript and I'm all about making
machine learning accessible to more
users which is great but you know I
scratch my head a lot trying to make
Python go faster so I'm like god why are
we moving to the JavaScript it's gonna
be slow and terrible and here are 50
reasons why I was super wrong so you've
already seen we can do interactive ml
which is huge we can do client-side ml
which is huge but putting some of those
together like here a couple amazing
things just right off the shelf that are
nuts the Wi-Fi here is actually pretty
so I pre-loaded this just in case but we
don't need it so this is a model called
pose net and it's running live in the
browser and maybe some of you have seen
it and I'm almost certainly gonna
accidentally destroy the bluejeans
setup but I'm just gonna carefully
horribly point this at y'all
and so I can't see what's happening so
this is not meant for this many people
but already this is not right
so like seeing this it's immediately
apparent yeah doing this in Python would
be a nightmare though another really
important takeaway from Joseph's talk
which I'm new to though obviously you
can compare tensorflow models to run in
tensorflow j/s but Joseph's working was
in PI torch also converted to run
intensive projects so this is a this is
a big deal and then okay in the same
family as opposed net there's body pics
and this was work out of I believe NYU
and Google I'm from New York oh yeah and
this is body pics and I'm not body pics
this is a segmentation doohickey and so
this I won't point it's gonna break but
you can see this is doing real-time
segmentation and these models are
running really really fast and obviously
to switch it something like mobile net
or whatever even quicker um so yeah so
those are two things right off the bat I
will come back to Oh
so obviously vision has like the best
demos everybody likes vision and stuff
like that
but there's a ton of important work in
text and so probably like the most
boring lesson I have to teach my teach
this stuff it's like okay kids let's do
like sends me analysis and text
classification which are really
important but people fall asleep but
anyway the only time I've actually been
excited when I've seen text
classification is text classification
running in the browser which immediately
is more interesting so here we have some
this is probably like a I don't know
what this is this is some basic time
series model but anyway we're doing
sentiment analysis hey how's it so we
can say that movie was great and we can
see it's positive terrible screen so
super cool and interactive in real time
so yeah a lot of value here other things
that I pulled right out of the bag of
demos I don't think we have time for
this since I want to leave a lot of time
for Q&A while we have a couple of
experts here that really really know
what they're talking about
but you can try this at home there is a
pacman demo and this is a way to control
pac-man with the webcam and basically
the idea here I think there's two
different models I think this one is
actually doing transfer learning and so
what its gonna do is to go left or
whatever you just hold down on the mouse
and you collect a bunch of training data
so when it awkwardly sees my head
looking at you all it's gonna be left
and then you see we can fly through this
if I'm not in screen at all it's gonna
go up and then let me just mess up the
other two really quickly just so I can
show you how this works so great and
then anyway you hit train and then we've
just trained some model on top of
probably mobile net and then if we hit
play and then I guess if I want to go
left and then up what I'm gonna do is
just awkwardly have my head right here
and that should send it left as soon as
it starts playing not sure what's going
on wave happening something terrible has
happened
but anyway it's probably excited 15
applications open using the webcam but
anyway you can check out the pac-man
game it's super cool I've got like a
billion things here let me kill body
pics well whatever
it will recognize the gesture and
control pac-man so that's super super
cool um anyway these things are great
with kids it's also if you're trying to
motivate people to learn machine
learning I mean obviously these are all
extremely hard to build but you can't
really do better than pac-man so there's
a lot of value there okay so other
things just to summarize some things of
what's been said so tensorflow 2 is all
about ease of use which is great but I
think from the from a teaching
perspective and also a research
perspective basically what I really like
about it is progressive disclosure of
complexity and so basically we have a
spectrum and the there's super easy ways
to define your model and that's easy
some things like the sequential model
for stacks it's a wonderful place to
start teaching with sequential and fit
then we've things like functional for
DAGs and then we have sub classing for a
chain at PI torch full customization
which is really really nice and what
this means especially if your students
in a classroom setting if you're doing
outreach and things like that in your
free time is you can sort of get
students up and running and they can
make their code work
as they're ready for more sophisticated
concepts you can expose them when
they're helpful so that's great and then
likewise when we're training models the
same thing is true if you know your
model happens to fit into the model dot
fit training paradigm awesome model dot
fit and you're done the other really
nice thing about model dot fit it's
performant but it's also easy to
maintain so if you don't need to write a
custom training every time don't and
then if you do need to we have gradient
Apes which by the way custom training
loops work the same way with sequential
models functional models subclass models
it doesn't matter
likewise model dot fit works with all
those models as well also if you check
out our distributed training tutorials
though by the way here are the latest
resources so tensorflow 2 is like two
weeks old so I'm used to typing tensor
floated org slash beta but now
everything is just a tensor flow org so
here are the latest resources not
surprisingly penser floated org we just
got rid of our beta website penser
floated org slash tutorials has all the
latest tutorials in case you're new to
well I'll come back to this basically
our resources are divided into tutorials
and guides and the tutorials are
basically short examples of common tasks
and the guides over here have more
detail and background so for distributed
training speaking of these different
levels of abstraction
we've got distribute training with care
us and this is probably modeled fit and
just like you've seen before all you
need to do to do distributed training
which I really really like is basically
adding a with block and now you have
this fancy all reduce you know one
machine multiple GPUs training strategy
which is great and then also you'll see
right down the road we have custom
training loops those complexity as you
need it and then just because some
people are new to this division a lot of
Google products have this tutorials and
guide things and Pritchard came from
Android or it might have predated that
you'll also find that we have a lot more
background on what these different
strategies are another good resource
that I want to point you at right now in
case you're new to it on YouTube and you
search for this is my presentation
account so who knows what these
recommendations are you search for
inside tensorflow
distributed training
and this is a new series there we go
so basically these are just there's a
whole bunch of these this is Josh
Levenberg and you know he's one of the
many engineers working on distributed
training but these are basically
low-budget tech talks and these are
internal trainings and you can see that
you know it's just dude with the camera
just filming Josh and Josh will give
like a 60-minute deep dive on
distributed training and I to be honest
I usually don't watch videos they're too
slow
I look at the transcripts and I read
them or I like to read the slides at the
summary but I've been spending some time
watching these because they're really
really good resource and there's also
one from Francois it's actually two
hours it's just all the details you want
to know exactly how what happens when
you call model that fit exactly what
happens when you write a custom layer
how layers
relate to models and how you write
custom metrics and losses it's
everything um so this is a really really
good resource anyway and these are all
targeted towards people of your skill
level so there's serious talks they have
a lot of detail they're fast so they're
good and there's a bunch of them all
right other resources that I can point
you at we're moving our blog to our own
server pretty soon but the best way to
stay informed of what's happening with
tensorflow is we have a blog right now
on medium and we have a mixture of
articles on there I just spoke with some
people that gave talks I really like
they're both from the tensorflow team
but also the community if you have work
that you think is of interest to the
community at large and you're interested
in sharing it you can shoot me an email
we can take a look at it by the way
there's my email address anyone who's
doing teaching or outreach and has any
like tensorflow questions or would like
tensorflow slides and happy to help feel
free to shoot me a line drop me a line
rather we have a Twitter that's where
updates are and then I wanted to mention
more things about the tutorials so
here's sort of the state of where we are
at this point
I know these are a little bit
disorganized but at this point we have a
pretty good bag of stuff so if you're
interested in gans and this question
came up earlier and it turns out the
person that asked it probably knows way
more about Gans than I do but if you're
interested in seeing like hey you know
if
heard about this pi torch style model
but I've never actually seen like a
serious implementation where can I find
it the fastest way is just go to our
tutorials and here's one for cycle fan
which is awesome and what's cool is
every single tutorial we have on this
page is tensorflow ready for tensor flow
- they all have complete code so you can
download these on github or open them up
in collab and every single one will run
end to end and I really really like this
because you know the expression trust
but verify
so whenever somebody tells me you know
I've seen so much and I've written so
much code that worked once and never
worked again and because all our
tutorials are runnable end to end cycle
again the tutorials will have these cute
pictures at the top and the code will
produce exactly those pictures so this
is great we also have an enormous
collection of models on github and the
main difference is the tutorials are
trying to have the minimum ish amount of
code to show the concept and what you'll
find on github is more production
quality research code but that's sort of
what we have for you all right I know
you know a lot of this stuff so I just
want to give you some points that came
up so just a quick slide I've stuck some
notes on for you if you're new to using
Karos inside tensorflow and TF chaos is
the superset of what you might be used
to would care us that i oh it's the
stuff with subclassing and grading tapes
and all that you should know that if you
happen to be using collab collab right
now has Kaos installed by default and it
has tensorflow one installed by default
and what you need to do is at the start
of your collab you need to install
tensorflow - the best way to install
tensorflow - we have a flag let me show
you how this looks so if i open up our
cycle game tutorial I scroll down at the
top we have some magic and so this is
just magic for collab if you run this o
garden that's the table of contents I
don't care about that it's back again we
have magic that you can use at the start
of all of our tutorials to install
tensorflow - and that will save you from
if installing it this will just switch
the runtime to a different version so
this is great
so that's the fastest way to get going
if you're new to this carrot stuff and
you want to try it out what you don't
want to do is import Karros if you do
that inside collab you're going to
import the reference implementation
which is multi back-end Karros basically
what you want is from tensorflow import
Karros and I see students make this
mistake all the time it's just it's our
fault for having collab setup the way it
is you just want to keep your eyes out
for using tensorflow back end if you see
that there's something wrong with your
imports just copy the imports from our
tutorials and you should be good to go
all right let's see I will give you guys
a choice so let's do this so we have it
is now 340 so we have 20 minutes left we
can do one of two things we can take the
next 20 minutes for QA or I can point
you to some code that you can run just
to get familiar with just some of these
new tensorflow 2.0 styles of writing
code I would suggest that we do QA
because we have experts here and the
truth is the best way to get familiar
with tensorflow to go through the
tutorials if you see anything that we
can improve please shoot me an email and
really appreciate your feedback one
thing that I personally like to do over
the next six months is especially for
researchers and especially for folks
familiar with PI torch I'd like to have
just PI torch has a really really
wonderful getting started you know with
like low-level tensors and gradients and
stuff like that I'd like to have
something similar but if there's content
that would be helpful that's missing
please let me know and I'll try and get
it on the website so basically if you're
new to this stuff and you want to start
from a research perspective under the
Advanced section I would go through this
customization flow which is really nice
and this will go into the details of
tensors and gradients and all that stuff
the guides also a really good resource
that an inside tensor flow is a really
really solid learning journey for simple
educational resources though for this is
all very very light reading but
especially for undergraduates and for
folks that want to dive into tensor flow
without really having what
strong math background yet I have three
hands-on book recommendations which are
really really good hands-on ml from
Marillion Girona is excellent if you
look at this book you definitely want
the second edition the first edition is
good too but it teaches tensorflow one
which you should skip it is not
necessary to learn tensorflow one who
are in tensorflow too but if you have
that's really useful foundational
knowledge deep learning with python is
the Carrows book it's wonderful for
students i've used it in a couple
classes as supplementary reading and
everybody's had a good time with it and
there's a javascript version of exactly
the same book which is also really good
alright so and then basically one
diagram that I thought might be helpful
to is this is sort of our flowchart of
it all right guess this is like a
business school 101 diagram right where
it's showing you like the different
development styles and tensorflow and
it's comparing them on these like easy
to use this is sort of the spectrum and
so that's that's what we're shooting for
and I'm really happy with it so far so
while we have people here what we can do
is stop recording I'm happy to take like
questions recorded but I want to dive in
especially like for researchers using PI
torch I'd really like to take the time
to understand what can we do to make
tensor flow to better suited to your use
cases